I'm excited today because I have a
special guest to introduce to the
channel named Tim Schmoyer now Tim runs
his own YouTube channel that's really
popular it teaches people how to become
YouTube creators I'm a subscriber I
watch every video that comes out and
usually i'm commenting on it and i
actually did a video on his channel the
you guys can check out i'll leave the
description in the link below and tim
has gone from having a full-time job to
be able to leave that and do YouTube
full time as a way to support his family
and now growing a business off of it and
I said Tim that's an awesome story and
invited him on to share his tip so he's
going to share his five tips for new
entrepreneurs and how to get started Tim
over to you hey guys my name is Tim
Schmoyer and Evan invited me to talk to
you guys a little bit about some of the
lessons that I've learned being a new
entrepreneur here on YouTube actually
the youtube channel at youtube.com /
video creators where I train people had
a master youtube to spread a message
that changes lives and I really really
really love doing that so I launched out
on my own doing this full-time about a
year and a half ago and turned YouTube
into my full-time business I've learned
many things mistakes as far as you know
being self-employed being an
entrepreneur and one of the first things
that I learned is that number ones that
I can't under myself like I shouldn't
undervalue myself like I came in to this
like my default thinking is that like
you know the stuff I know it's kind of
common sense you know a lot of people
would know this an icon just undervalued
it both in like my consulting fees and
in the training I was doing after some
time while people said note in like this
isn't common knowledge like you are
under estimating which you know and the
value that you are bringing and you're
actually almost bringing like too much
value for people to consume so as you
guys are getting started in business it
might be easy to think like ah you know
maybe you undervalue yourself undervalue
yourself and just kind of have a lot of
humility in that area but also maybe not
give yourself you know the value that
you actually deserved number to another
thing that I learned is that there are
many distractions that come your way
that are disguised as opportunities
there's no lack of things you could do
resources you could tap into
a a projects you could tackle people you
could work with you know and I've
learned that all a lot of them are good
opportunities but ultimately they're
they're distractions from me actually
you know nailing down what my core
business is what I can do the best and I
can do some of these other things may be
better than the average person but
they're not like my sweet spot and so I
end up taking like consulting gigs I
probably shouldn't have taken and I end
up you know speaking speaking
opportunities that I because I spoke on
it was ok but like those were all
distractions from really helping me
after that we're keeping me from really
driving home the main thing that I'm
really good at with audience development
with creators on YouTube another lesson
that I learned as a new entrepreneur is
number three and that is that I need to
stay in control of my own schedule it's
overwhelming the amount of things that
you could do with your day in your time
so one of the things I do for example is
I only scheduled phone calls and
meetings and consultations anything that
requires me talking with someone outside
my family and a business contacts those
conversations only happen on Thursdays
and Fridays otherwise my schedule just
gets really fragmented and i end up with
all these little blocks of time in
between phone calls and meetings that i
can't really be very productive in so
Saeng gain control of my schedule
something I learned is really important
for me as a new entrepreneur number four
kind of going along with that is that
I've learned I also really need to keep
the end goal in mind one of the reasons
why I work for myself as an entrepreneur
self-employed guy is so I can have the
flexibility and the freedom to spend
with my family and with my kids that I
want what is the angle why am i doing
business in the first place and make
sure that we keep our sights on that so
that we can say you know what I do have
a lot i need to do today at my business
but today I'm just going to stop and i'm
gonna go spend times my kids or my wife
or you know whatever i'm saying is
important to me i am making sure that
but business doesn't overtake and
control my life and number five I really
think you have to do something that
matters to people and to you because
guys you know that's renewer is like
working in a business that you are
starting is just so much work and energy
and time and commitment and tears and
emotes that everything are like invested
into that
that like if you don't know and believe
that what you're doing is actually
making a difference in someone's life
and it's actually contributing and you
know to the world and to your families
economy and everything like it's really
hard to keep going so definitely do
something that you know matters and if
you are interested in changing lives
through a tool like youtube it love for
you guys to come over to my channel
youtube.com slash video creators I think
I've been Carmichael will put a link in
the description below this video you
guys wanna go check it out or I'll train
you guys how to use YouTube to do is
just something just like that thanks Tim
for all the great tips for those of you
watching just to summarize Tim's five
tips for new entrepreneurs were number
one don't undervalue yourself number two
don't get distracted number three
control your schedule number four keep
your end goal in mind and number five do
something that matters and of course
believe so those are watching I
encourage you to go check out Tim's
channel subscribe to this channel if you
want to see more videos just like it and
I'd love to hear where your success tips
are for new entrepreneurs leave a
comment below so that other
entrepreneurs can learn from your
success as well thank you guys so much
for watching I'll see you soon hi ever
kill English here with mermaid junkie TV
are you on Evans newsletter subscription
if not you should be I read every single
one and you should too channel
you